à chaque jour son nouvel exercice et sa
nouvelle démonstration de force près de
kiev les réservistes de l'armée
ukrainienne multiplie les entraînements
pour se tenir prêt et envoyer un message
à la russie accusé de vouloir envahir le
pays s quoi dans ce camp en tailleur
vuitton je vis avec l'idée que tant que
nous n'aurons pas donné une bonne claque
à la russie elle ne nous laissera pas
tranquille il achève toujours les
faibles si nous ne nous défendons pas
cette invasion va nous maintenir à terre
pendant longtemps robe de lance de
moscou nie farouchement toute intention
malveillante mais dit se sentir menacé
et aurait massé près de cent mille
soldats la frontière ukrainienne ces
dernières semaines dix mille aurait été
rappelés dans leur bal samedi le kremlin
fait ainsi ouvertement pression pour
empêcher tout élargissement de l'otan à
l'ukraine ou à d'anciens pays
soviétiques
contenu de cette tension entre les deux
pays les pourparlers presque habituelles
prévues entre russes et américains
prennent une tournure toute particulière
le 10 janvier représentant de washington
et de moscou doivent se retrouver pour
renégocier les traités de contrôle
d'armement nucléaire mais l'ukraine
s'est invitée au menu des discussions
les états unis ont hâte d'engager un
dialogue avec la russie quand on ça
serra pour discuter la russie pourra
mettre ses inquiétudes sur la table et
nous mettrons les nôtres sur la table
notamment leur activité dialogue direct
donc mais aussi via l'otan le 12 janvier
puis l'oas et l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe le
lendemain washington tente ainsi
d'exploiter toutes les voies
diplomatiques pour amadouer moscou